Now we need to figure out how to use computed observables to
add functionality to our application.
Specifically, to add a cat name feature and a cat title feature.
In order to learn how to use them,
we'll take a look at the documentation together.
Now first off, every librarian framework has its own documentation and
libraries without documentation are not very effective to use.
So, if documentation is missing or
especially poor, nobody will want to use the library, and it won't take off.
Chances are if you've heard of a library before,
it probably has pretty good documentation.
Now Knockouts documentation, is actually more of a series of articles here,
rather than a traditional documentation site.
That's okay though because most of the information we need is here.
If you find the documentation lacking there is probably a blog post by
someone else illuminating the thing you're looking for and
to figure that part out I usually start with a Google search.
Now let's take a look at computed observables.
Now Knockout's documentation gives us a pretty good first explanation here,
introducing the concept of computed observables.
In this case, they're saying if we have a firsName and
a lastName, both observables, Bob Smith, how do we get the fullName?
Well rather than putting the joining logic Bob plus space plus Smith.
Everywhere, all over the place, instead we can define a computed observable.
Computed observables are awesome, and
they're pretty simple to implement in Knockout.
All you have to do,
is run ko.computed(), passing in the function that computes what you want.
And an optional suggested argument for
the thing that maps to the this keyword inside that function.
Basically, because of the way ko dot computed works, when we pass in this for
the second argument,
that ensures that we can use the this keyword inside the function.
And this means that we can use our other observables,
because we have access to the this that they're on.
So again, in summary, this.fullname equals ko.computed, and then a function
which simply returns firstName added to space, and then added to lastName.
Now we can use it like any other variable, this.fullName pretty cool.